you're an outspoken advocate for both
hustle and self-awareness yeah so if you
had to put them in order even if it's a
1 a and 1 self awareness self awareness
not when you know who Lou yes when you
know who you are
hustle sexier yeah like it would've been
cooler for like the people listening for
me to say hustle
cuz it's cooler self awareness is the
game in business the reason I've been so
successful is I know what I'm good at
and I know what I'm not good at yeah and
so when you actually understand yourself
you know many people are listening right
now that love athletics and think they
have a jump shot and think they can take
it to the rack daily that's right and
when and instead of taking a step back
and saying I suck going to my left and
then working on it yeah they continue to
[ __ ] themselves and they never Excel
self awareness and sports is that and in
business it's people that think they're
a good marketer or it's somebody who
thinks that they're good at selling or
somebody who thinks they're good at HR
or being a leader and the truth is you
may not be my friends if you're
listening right now if you just know who
you are if you know that you're short if
you know that you're fast if you know
that you can shoot if you know that
you're a good guy if you know that
you're a patient gal if if you know who
you are and do more of that and then
also understand whether you need to work
on those weaknesses or not so for
example in business I think actually not
working on your weakness is a good
strategy because you hire or partner up
around it the problem with basketball is
just being cliche here is if you never
work on your left hand you're never
gonna have it so you know and it limits
you so I think self-awareness is the
single most important drug in society